so today I thought it'd be a good time
to revisit the subject of how computer
memory works if you remember from a few
previous computer files several years
ago we looked at how we could store
information a single bit of information
in an electronic circuit so we took the
classic nor gate we took two of them in
fact vaguely an or gate and we wired
them up so the output of one fed back to
the input of the other and vice versa
and they only had two inputs in that
could be used to reset or set the output
and we had two outputs that were the
opposite of each other and this circuit
if you built it you can go watch the
previous episode would be either be set
to be one if this pin was taken one and
you would remember that it been set or
you could reset it if this bit was taken
to be one which point it would then go
to be false or zero until you changed it
and that circuit would remember a single
bit of information and then we saw how
we could build that up and use multiple
of them to store lots of information we
gave each one an address and then we
arranged them in and a grid and we split
that address up to refer to the row and
column so we could access each
individual bit now that stores single
bits and we can have multiple ones that
we can address individually by giving it
a binary address and if we wanted to
store multiple bits all we do is have
multiple ones then want to store each
bit and run them in parallel so we'll
concentrate on using a single [ __ ] but
if we look at a normal memory chip as a
sim from long ago but is actually one
two three four five six seven eight
different chips on here that are used to
store each of the individual bits that
make up the bike we can build this
circuit it stores a single bit of
information but we're using four
transistors minimum to store each bit
which seems a lot and is there a way we
can store it using less now this type of
memory is what's called static RAM
because once you've store the bit it'll
remember that until the power turned off
as we said before we can arrange these
into a grid and so let's say we're gonna
use store for bits I story one bit
that's doing another that's doing
another that's doing another and then we
can address them from the row so this
would be Rosie Rose you'd be wrong
this would be column zero this would be
pollen one and then we can refer to each
individual cell on there and we could
expand that out we could go up to four
by four and so on and now we can refer
to any of the 16 things by giving it
address those 0 0 0 1 1 1 0 0 1 1 0 1 2
1 1 1 1 over here but as we said we need
to use 4 transistors for each of these
cells and that's going to sort of set
however much silicon we've got that's
going to be the limit of how much RAM we
can get on there unless we can get the
size of this down so is there a way we
can build a memory circuit which uses
less than four transistors the answer is
yes but it comes with a problem the
advantage of building static memory like
we saw before is as soon as it's turned
on and set it remembers that until you
turn the power off if you want to reduce
the number of transistors used we have
to compromise that and say ok we're
going to let the memory forget we're
going to build a memory circuit that
inherently is built to forget that the
information is stored and this is what
we use inside all computers these days
the memory that you're building will
forget what is stored after about 64
milliseconds now how does that work well
the way we do that is by using not just
a transistor but a transistor and a
capacitor so we build each memory cell
rather than from four to six transistors
we build them from one transistor and
one capacitor now why does that work
what I've got here wired up is an LED
resistor just to stop it exploding or
the coolant getting too great for it to
be more accurate and a switch so I can
turn it on and off and so the circuit is
relatively straightforward we've got a
power source I have a switch I have an
LED giving off light and I have a
resistor probably 330 ohms that classic
thing when I close that switch that
light comes on but let's also modify
that circuits line you said that we've
got a capacitor in there what we're
going to do is we're going to wire it up
so we've got 0 volts now return down
here we've got +5
here and we're going to put the
capacitor in parallel with the LEDs or
so in our switch and we're gonna have
the LED and the resistor but alongside
that we'll have the capacitor as well so
that's why that up and we should see a
difference so when I turn it on now when
I press the switch a light comes on when
I let go it goes off for those
interested at home I'm using a 470 micro
farad capacitor here so we put that in
the circuit and now when I press the
button the light comes on but when I let
go it gradually dies down click it and
the light dies down though what's going
on here well the capacitor is a
component that stores charge so as I
close this switch current flows down
through the LED but it also flows into
the capacitor and it stores the charge
of charge accumulates between these two
plates so the current flows down here at
the lights the LED when I close the
switch but it also flows down starts to
charge the top plate of the capacitor so
that when I let go of the switch the
charge can then flow around this to form
a circuit but the charge is a new small
amount and it as we see it decays over
time and it starts to run out but that
capacitor actually stores whether it's
at 5 volts or at zero volts if we don't
charge it then it's a zero volts or it's
at 5 volts and you store that for a
short period of time in that canoed of
time is dependent on the type of
capacity if I change this for a 47 micro
farad capacitor
make sure I get it the right way around
otherwise there might be an explosion
the same thing is happening as the slow
motion shows changing the capacitance of
the capacitor changes the amount of time
that the information is stored for a
larger capacitor stores it for a longer
period of time
but we've got a problem we've got a
circuit here which can store information
for a short period of time and the
capacitors typically used in dynamic Ram
circuits in the computer the
recommendation is that it'll last for
about sixty four milliseconds or a bit
longer but that's no good we want our
computer to remember things so how do we
get around it well let's look at the
circuit again as I press it we can see
it's decaying and if I wanted to store
that I could say that's obviously our
now
again and I'll press it again and I'll
press it again and every time I press it
it starts the decay process from full
brightness again and as long as I can
refreshing what's stored in there and
keep pressing the button then it stays
on and it stays on and it stays on and
that's exactly what the computer does
every 64 milliseconds it looks at that
bit of information that's stored on
there works out whether it's a zero or
one that's been stored and stores it
again and then 64 milliseconds later it
looks at it and stores it again and on
and on and on and on and so on so we've
got a circuit now that can store a bit
information for a short period of time
but we need to refresh it otherwise we
lose the information in there actually
this is not that much different from the
first computer core memories that we use
way back when when when you've read the
information you destroyed it so you have
to store it back in again so it has
precedent but we can use this as the
basis of a thing because we can build a
capacitor in a single transistor in much
less space when I say they can ship than
we use for transistors to do it we store
it in exactly the same arrangement and
rather than having a physical switch
like I had there we use a transistor as
a switch so each of our cells will
become a capacitor which is connected to
ground and we have a transistor and then
we can put them into a grid arrangement
as we had before and again we can
address them as zero zero zero one one
zero one one for the row and zero zero
zero one one zero one one for the column
but we have another problem with the
static Ram chips that we had before they
store five volts or zero volts with a
capacitor as we saw it's decaying as
it's going on so rather than just having
the values coming straight out the
capacitor you need to have some extra
circuits here which are called the sense
amplifiers which take the value from the
bit and convert it to being a zero or
one at zero or 5 volts or whatever
system the computers using so we can't
just take the value directly like we
could before we need an extra bit
of circuitry in there to amplify it to
the right levels and the way these are
arranged is that you select a particular
row of the dynamic Ram circuit let's say
we want to select row zero one and the
sense amplifiers are then switched to be
connected to that and whatever values
are stored in there let's say we've got
one zero one zero and then sort of read
from there and they're produced out as
the output at the end and this leads to
an interesting property because whenever
we select a value from memory in dynamic
Ram we have to copy this through the
sense amplifiers and then it's buffered
using effectively some sort of static
Ram type stuff after that which means
that it takes longer to select a new row
than to switch between a different
column so once we've selected a row so
be very quick to switch from reading on
this row column 0 0 to column 0 1 but
we'd have to reload the things if we
wanted to go and read from row 0 0
column 0 0 so if we can speed things up
slightly by reading across the row each
time and actually if you use a CPU cache
you can preload your cache lines by
using that but what we can also do is
once we've read this in we can sort of
feed the values back in to refresh our
circuit and this is called dynamic Ram
refresh and you need to build that in if
you're going to use dynamic Ram on your
computer which is what most computers do
these days you need to build that in to
your actual system and these various
ways you can do it you could do it
literally in software the original Sun
one micro workstation actually had code
that refreshed the dynamic Ram every 64
milliseconds it was an interrupt it was
fired and it just went through reading
the values from each of those locations
which caused the RAM chips to update it
problem with that is if your program
crashes then you can't debug it because
your whole memory gets wiped so these
days is actually usually built into
hardware and actually what will happen
is after a certain amount of time 64
milliseconds the hardware will go
through and refresh each of the rows of
the dynamic Ram in turn to refresh each
of the memories
the data that's stored there now
actually in reality you probably won't
do it all in one go you'd stop it
regularly and do a row at a time and go
through then you'd start again each of
the way through and there's lots of
support built into various chips to do
this it's an interesting thing about
this though when we built static RAM the
data is stored until the power goes off
as soon as the power goes off then the
value is stored we're using capacitors
here and so it's an interesting side
effect in that perhaps can share it with
this I haven't wired this up but I'm
gonna turn my light on and charge it and
rather than letting go the switch I am
going to pull the power supply out and
even though there's no power into the
circuit because that capacitor is built
at charge as I remove it then it still
stores a bit of data and this actually
happens in your dynamic RAM chips if you
pull the power where as static Ram would
forget everything the dynamic Ram chips
store the data for a short period of
time and interestingly while the dynamic
RAM chips manufacturers say you need to
refresh it after six before 64
milliseconds is up in reality it can
sometimes be a bit longer I've seen
computers where this has managed to stay
for over 10 seconds after the powerful
machines and actually one of the
security risks for computers that the
capacitance change is dependent on
temperature so if you get hold with
someone's computer and make it very very
cold and reboot it in a particular way
you've a good chance of being able to
recover data that was in their memory so
we can start off by putting a NAND gate
in here connected to that so now we have
when a in contains 0 we're gonna do is
try and find the peak ok these these
values so actually we're starting off in
focus here and we've got a value of
about 5 million